elon just claimed that tesla will ship a
fully functional humanoid robot by next
year naturally the press thinks it's
impossible but could he actually do it
let's look at what's possible now boston
dynamics already has a robot that can do
parkour and 10 years ago they built a
robot that could run at 28 miles per
hour the teslabot will only go 5 miles
per hour so it doesn't seem impossible
in fact if elon wanted to release a
robot that matched the capabilities of
boston dynamics next year he could and
i'm being a hundred percent serious
boston dynamics is only worth one
billion dollars but elon is worth over
180 billion dollars so he could just buy
boston dynamics paint the atlas robot
black and start producing them next year
obviously elon isn't going to do that
but the fact that he could should make
you pause before you say that the tesla
bot will not ship next year and even if
elon misses his target ship date by
years does it really matter two things
are clearly true building the teslabot
doesn't break the laws of physics so
it's possible and building such an
advanced piece of technology will
require lots of smart people to work on
the project and that's why tesla is
recruiting so aggressively elon is known
for always announcing unrealistic
timelines and then missing them
sometimes by years but i think this is a
lot less important than most people seem
to think everyone agrees that steve jobs
was one of the most impactful
technologists of the last hundred years
but he missed deadlines all the time too
in 1983 he said that he wanted to build
a networked computer the size of a book
and would ship it by the end of the
decade apple strategy is really simple
what we want to do is we want to put an
incredibly great computer in a book that
you can carry around with you that you
can learn how to use in 20 minutes we
want to do it this decade and we really
want to do it with a radio link in it so
you don't have to hook up to anything
you're in communication with all these
larger databases and other computers
well the first ipad didn't ship until
2010 so jobs missed his prediction by a
full 20 years but it didn't matter at
all in the time between 1983 and 2010
apple shipped dozens of incredible
products that moved the entire industry
forward looking back now no one
remembers that jobs missed that deadline
just that when he finally did ship the
ipad it was a great product that steve
jobs clip comes from a talk he gave in
aspen and his goal with the talk was to
recruit talented engineers to come work
for apple elon is doing the exact same
thing with ai day he's highlighting all
of the incredible advances that tesla
has made in the field of self-driving
and teasing what's going to come next
and it's the advances in self-driving
that we should really be focusing on
because the stuff that tesla is doing
right now is absolutely incredible
the entire company has basically
transformed over the past two decades
what started as a hardware company
focused on building cars has transformed
into a software company focused on
building self-driving technology and now
the ai models that power tesla's
self-driving cars have become so complex
that tesla has gone a layer deeper and
become a hardware company that makes
computer chips it's really incredible
stuff during tesla's ai day elon's team
explained how they are tackling hard
problems across three key domains the
first is the core neural network
architecture that powers autopilot it's
a common misperception that self-driving
cars use a single ai system to process
camera data and then control the car
there are a few companies that are
trying to do that type of end-to-end
self-driving like comma ai but tesla
actually breaks the problem down into
smaller parts ai is only used to
understand the environment around the
car the actual decision making about
where to drive within that environment
is done using more traditional software
development techniques even though tesla
could use machine learning to plan out
the route taken by the car they don't
and elon had a great explanation as for
why as long as you've got like surround
video neural nets for understanding
what's going on and can convert the
surround video into vector space then
you basically have a video game if
you're in grand theft auto whatever you
can you can make the cars drive around
and pedestrians walk around without
crashing you don't have to have a neural
net for control and planning see
programmers have been able to design
basic systems for cars and video games
for years that react to environments and
avoid collisions that part is actually
not that hard the hard part is
understanding the real world and all of
its incredible variations as if it was
as simple as a video game
elon stressed the importance of surround
video and vector space because that's
where tesla took a big step forward
fortunately those two phrases sound more
complicated than they actually are
surround video just means stitching all
of the different cameras around the car
into one big image years ago when tesla
implemented the first version of
autopilot the car only had one camera so
this wasn't an issue the only job of the
autopilot was to keep you in the lane
and stop you from running into a car
directly in front of you but now tesla
cars ship with lots of cameras placed
all around the car this creates a ton
more data for the machine learning
algorithms to process and up until
recently the tesla systems were dealing
with each camera feed individually this
caused some problems though like when a
big truck appeared on multiple cameras
it became very difficult to understand
exactly where that truck was in the real
world allowing the system to see all the
cameras at once as surround video also
made it possible to translate the
two-dimensional images into
three-dimensional representations that's
what elon is talking about when he says
vector space the new autopilot system
now takes all of the camera images and
creates a fully 3d representation of the
data just like a video game and this has
some powerful implications especially on
the second key tesla innovation training
data every machine learning system needs
data and there are three main ways that
companies generally get that data the
most reliable data is hand labeled by a
human but that's very expensive using a
separate ai system to automatically
label data is much cheaper but it can be
prone to error lastly you can create an
infinite amount of data that's perfectly
labeled using simulated environments but
that has drawbacks too ai experts have
debated which kind of data is best for
years but tesla just said yes and to all
three kinds they hired a thousand data
labelers built an automated system for
labeling the data that the humans
couldn't get to in time and then also
developed a remarkably realistic
simulation environment for generating
even more data all of these systems help
teach autopilot about various situations
that it might see in the real world and
they all support each other and help
fill in gaps in the data for example the
simulated environment is great for
creating bizarre scenarios like a group
of people running down the middle of a
highway it's unlikely to happen in the
real world but if it does happen you'll
want your tesla to know what to do and
all of this is aided by that move to
vector space that elon mentioned human
labelers can now manually identify a
traffic cone in a 3d environment that
looks like a video game and the raw
images from each camera that saw that
traffic cone will be updated
automatically this three-pronged
approach shows that the autopilot team
isn't turning away any good ideas
they'll use every tool at their disposal
to build a reliable system but doing so
creates new problems tesla now has
hundreds of thousands of cars sending in
real world video feeds every single day
and most of those video feeds get
labeled either by humans or automated
systems so the ai team at tesla now has
an immense amount of data to work with
they retrain their models from start to
finish multiple times per month which
means running all of that data through a
massive supercomputer in order to
recalculate the entire neural network
this is an incredibly computationally
complex task and it has to be done on a
special type of computer chip
traditionally the training of neural
networks has been done using graphics
processing units or gpus and there's
really only one major player in the gpu
space at the moment nvidia the problem
is that nvidia has increased their
prices to the point where it no longer
makes sense for big companies like tesla
but there is another option in 2016
google released the tensor processing
unit or tpu it's a chip specifically
designed for training these machine
learning models it's a good option for
many companies but it wouldn't work for
tesla because they are in direct
competition with google see you can buy
an nvidia graphics card and basically do
whatever you want with it but google's
tpus are kept behind lock and key in
google's cloud data centers and in order
to use them you have to agree to their
terms of service the thing is one of the
clauses in that agreement states that
you promise not to use their systems to
train self-driving cars so that option
is off the table for tesla but elon saw
this coming and had the tesla team start
building their own d1 chips that would
serve as the basis for a new
supercomputer called dojo that could be
used to train autopilot they still
haven't deployed this system fully but
for anyone who is paying close attention
this was by far the biggest announcement
of the day the scale of everything that
they are doing is absolutely insane a
single d1 chip is a thousand times more
powerful than a brand new ps5 and tesla
has connected one million of these chips
together to create their compute center
the complete system has 1.1 extra flops
of computing power which is so massive
it's likely the most powerful
supercomputer ever created the
combination of improvements to the
neural network training data and
underlying hardware are going to
compound to help tesla finally get
across the finish line and deliver full
self-driving but elon obviously isn't
stopping there after over an hour of
technical demonstrations elon decided to
have some fun and spent five minutes
talking about the teslabot he's clearly
having fun with it but i do think he
really believes that tesla will be able
to transfer a lot of the work that
they've done in self-driving to the
humanoid form but there's a big question
why try to make it look so much like a
person science fiction authors have been
writing about humanoid robots for
decades but building something with all
the flexibility of a human body is
incredibly difficult after all it's much
easier to build a robot vacuum than an
actual robot that vacuums i think the
humanoid form could actually wind up
being an intermediate step on the path
to even more useful robots kind of like
how apple tried to make everything look
analog in the first versions of the
iphone consider the calculator app in
the 1980s running calculations on a
computer required keying in values on
the command line the device looked
nothing like a real world calculator but
when apple released the iphone they
opted for a skeuomorphic design that
mimicked physical calculators only after
a few years did apple realize that users
didn't need this familiarity and so they
opted for a more minimal design the same
could be true for robotics we could move
from irobot vacuum cleaners to teslabots
and then to something entirely new we
don't quite know but i'm excited to see
where it goes and remember even if elon
delivered the teslabot in the year 2040
he would still be faster at shipping
than steve jobs and that would be pretty
incredible thanks for watching